hey what is going on YouTube you know
one of the things I have never been able
to do is say no to food even when I
really shouldn't eat something I know
you're not gonna believe this
given in this Big Mac there's a strain
of bacteria from a cow in Japan that was
resistant to any form of aggressive
segmentation wait hold on are you
telling me that this Big Mac with two
all-beef patties special sauce lettuce
cheese pickles and onions on a
sesame-seed bun' how's the cure to
cancer yes
at no cost was getting to the wrong
oh my bad do all that 100 what I'm not
like most people I've come to realize
that because most people eat food not
just because they enjoy it they do it
because it is a necessity that's right
you your normal ass freaks you eat to
survive not maybe I eat until I hate
myself like when you jack off to some
weird-ass porn and then after you come
you realize how disgusting of a human
being you are just me you ever go out to
eat sometimes and then immediately after
your meal you go home and open up a bag
of chips that's me it's like what the
[ __ ] why did you do that you're not
hungry you sick Frank eating after your
stomach hurts from being too full it's
like trying to [ __ ] after you just took
a [ __ ] it's counterintuitive to what
your body wants look I feel like I lost
10 pounds most of the times when I'm
doing this I don't know that I'm doing
it it's a terrible habit refer back to
the weird masturbation joke so many
times I've woken up and asked but by the
time I realized I eaten the double
dinner it's too late it's like the
moment I see food
I turned into no Beast werewolf hey man
I didn't know you were home I'm gonna
need you to relax just a little just
you got this this is just my god
with me I realize food is a major social
thing you know like if we're going to
hang out we're going to eat I know I
don't have to but I can't help myself
people have even suggested just going
out for coffee and to that I replied
[ __ ] your coffee
I know uncalled for right but that's
just me but I realized that never saying
no to going out to eat or eating free
food can be the cause of a few things
number one being consistently broke
going out to eat is expensive as hell
yet dumb [ __ ] I'm talking to myself
and if there's just going out to eat so
you can hang out not only are you
spending money at home on food you're
double-dipping when you go out so either
you're eating way too much food or
you're letting the food in the fridge go
to waste
wasteful them until ridiculous weight
gain I'm eating healthy what is this why
my breast size is 2 yeah you ain't
healthy David but you ate healthy 12
times you're big [ __ ] you're healthy
option or your meal was not an hors
d'oeuvre it was a meal between so much
but it's okay not to eat socially I
realized I don't have to eat food
because other people are eating
leftovers my friends apparently isn't a
myth that [ __ ] exists when I'm full I
can't stop